president Trump's former campaign
manager is still facing charges filed by
Special Counsel Robert Muller a federal
judge did not dismiss the indictment of
Paul Manafort but he was skeptical of
mowers authority in the case Jeff Pegues
has more on the hearing in Alexandria
Virginia and the president's reaction to
it to which on on Friday President Trump
seized on the judges words as evidence
that the special counsels investigation
had gone too far
judge questions Muller's authority to
prosecute manifold former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort was indicted by
the special counsel on bank fraud
charges in connection to his alleged
activities predating the 2016 election
but during a court hearing Friday US
District Judge TS Ellis wondered whether
in pursuing the case against mana for
special counsel Robert Muller had
exceeded his mandate to investigate
Russian election interference Ellis said
the special counsel was trying to
tighten the screws on mana for in order
to force him to testify against the
president you don't really care about Mr
Man affords bank fraud what you really
care about is what information mr. mana
fort can give you that would reflect on
mr. Trump or lead to his prosecution or
impeachment but Deputy Solicitor General
Michael Dreeben who represented Muller's
office during the hearing responded we
take very seriously the primary mission
that was assigned to us well the
president praised the judge and used his
comments to rally supporters against the
Russia investigation it is unclear what
kind of effect the judges comments will
actually have on the special counsels
investigation and the special counsels
case against Paul Manafort attorneys who
have faced judge Ellis in the past say
that his comments are not always a
reflection of how he will actually rule
for CBS this morning Saturday Jeff
Pegues Washington